[MUSIC PLAYING]
BLAKE DUBOIS: Hello, everyone.
Thanks for joining us.
Today, we're going
to talk about how
Pandora moved and migrated
its on-premises BI
and analytics to GCP.
I'm joined by Brett, who's VP
of platform services at Pandora
Media.
And I myself am Blake DuBois.
I'm part of the professional
services organization
at Google Cloud, helping
some of our largest customers
move and migrate
their Hadoop to GCP.
We are going to be
using a Dory today.
It's accessible
through your Next app.
We encourage everyone
who has questions,
now or throughout the talk,
to just go into the app,
jot them down.
If you have time to look
at the existing questions
and possibly upvote them,
at the end of the talk,
we're going to be taking
questions from the audience
at the microphones and
the Dory, alternating.
Thank you.
And lastly, just a little
bit about the agenda.
Brett's going to give an
introduction to Pandora
and talk about the
big data evolution.
We're going to talk
about why Pandora
chose to move to the cloud,
and GCP specifically.
Some of the evaluation
results that took place
before their
commitments, and we're
going to go into some
of the technical details
around the solution
rearchitecture
before finalizing with the rest
of the roadmap for the year,
and what we hope to see
Pandora present at Next 2020.
Brett?
BRETT UYESHIRO: Cool.
Thanks, Blake.
All right.
So who we are--
Pandora.
Can we get a show of
hands-- how many of you
have used the
Pandora app before?
All right.
That's a great showing.
Thank you very
much for listening.
Another show of
hands-- how many of you
have used our on-demand
service, our premium?
OK.
Pretty good.
Now how many of you know
that you can search and play
with our free,
ad-supported version?
Have you tried out
that feature yet?
Even smaller group.
OK.
Well, go check it out.
It's a really exciting feature.
We launched it a few months ago.
We're really excited about it.
But one of the things
we do at Pandora
that's really at sort
of the core of Pandora
is our personalization.
So the idea with
Pandora is that you can
have a lean back experience.
You give us some cues, and we
program a continuous stream
of content for you, whether
it's music or non-music content,
like podcasts or comedy.
So at the heart of
this personalization
is our analytics system.
It's really the
workhorse behind it.
So we have a lot of data.
68 million users in the US.
Those users have created over 13
billion stations over the life
of Pandora, and 90 billion
pieces of feedback--
thumbs up or thumbs down--
telling us what they
like or don't like.
And we use all that data
for this personalization.
So I'll tell you a little bit
about the history of big data
at Pandora.
I've actually been
at Pandora 11 years
and was really involved since
the beginning with analytics
at Pandora.
So we launched Pandora in 2005.
In 2008, 2009, mobile
really exploded
and the usage of
Pandora really took off.
So originally, we had a
single Postgres database.
We were stuffing all of
our analytics data into it,
and it didn't scale very
well, as you can imagine.
So 2010, we started
experimenting
with Hadoop on-prem, and we
built out our first Hadoop
cluster, moved all of our
analytics over to Hadoop.
Started with a very
modest cluster--
10 servers, Apache
0.17 and Hive 0.5.
And we've grown
on-prem quite a bit.
So every year, we've had growth.
We've added more engineers, more
analysts, more scientists, all
working on a single cluster.
We have one production
cluster that
runs everything on Pandora.
And we've also added a lot
of personalization features.
So thumbprint
radio, if any of you
use that, personalized
soundtracks, AutoPlay,
all these personalized
features for our listeners.
We've also added features
for our advertisers, as well.
Really cool campaign
reporting tools,
some really advanced
forecasting so
that they can make sure they
have the right campaign,
and some cool segmenting
and targeting, as well.
So with all those features,
with all that growth,
we grew the cluster.
So today, we are up to 2,700
datanodes, 7 petabytes of data,
and quite a few
resources on this thing--
so 270 terabytes of
RAM, 76,000 vcores.
Just a 10,000-foot overview of
how analytics works at Pandora.
We have the data
ingestion side of things.
We leverage Kafka
really heavily.
Almost all of our
real-time event data
that happens as you
trigger actions in the app
comes through Kafka now.
We use Sqoop and
some homegrown tools
to load data from our relational
databases into Hadoop.
So load all that stuff into
HDFS, leverage Hive and Spark
very heavily for all our
ETL and batch workloads.
Presto and Hive are
the primary tools
that our scientists,
developers, analysts
use as they're
looking for insights.
We also have a couple BI
tools we rely on heavily--
Zeppelin and Tableau
for insights.
And then a large percentage
of what our workload
is on the cluster
are really jobs
that our development
team, our science team
has built doing
that personalization
and pushing that personalization
that we do typically in a batch
process into production
stores that we
can run our real-time
services off of and make
these decisions in real time.
So Postgres and
Redis, in particular,
we rely on really heavily.
So disaster recovery with our
current on-prem architecture--
we have our main colo,
which is in San Jose.
We do have a backup.
I would call it more of a
business continuity backup, not
true disaster recovery.
We have a much smaller
cluster, very data-dense,
that's located outside of DC.
We have a 40-gigabyte
link that we
copy data to pretty
much all the time
to keep at least a copy
of our data up-to-date.
But the big drawback
with this is
if we did need to failover and
rely on our backup data center,
it would take us some time to
scale that out to really take
on the production workload.
It's just not feasible to run
two clusters the same size.
It would just be sitting
idle all the time.
So why cloud?
You know, we've been
on-prem for a long time.
Why would we kind of pick
up and move to the cloud?
And that was a big
question for us.
So a lot of different reasons.
Bursty workloads is a
really interesting one.
Let me just put a pin
in that for a minute.
There's a cool slide I
want to show you next that
gets into that a little bit.
But another avenue
of flexibility
is hardware choices.
So we have different workloads.
Some of them-- Spark, Presto--
very memory-intensive.
They can do a lot with the
memory if you give it to them.
And all of our
jobs are different.
We have one single
cluster, and we
run a lot of different
types of workloads.
So being able to
switch to a model
where we've separated
storage and compute,
and we can spin up
purpose-driven clusters
with different profiles
for different workloads,
is really appealing to us.
Also, multi-regional.
I mentioned the DR
situation for us.
Being able to have a
true disaster recovery
is pretty cool.
Reduce maintenance-- as the
cluster's grown the last two
or three years, we've spent
more and more of our time
operationally just keeping
the cluster running for all
of our users--
we've got about 150 users on
the cluster across the company--
and managing the
resources between them.
And we've hit quite a few bugs
just because of our scale.
Things like storage
tiering, and also
understanding costs at
a more granular level,
has been really cool.
So this is another one
on flexibility here.
This is a chart of our Hadoop
utilization over a month.
And if you look
at this chart, you
say, OK, well, things
are looking pretty good.
You're under 40%, 35%
across the board as a mean.
But because we run
one cluster, we
have a lot of
different users on it,
we're actually
resource-constrained
a lot of the time.
People come in the morning.
They want to execute
their queries.
They want to learn about what
happened the previous day.
And so we have
bottleneck and backup.
So even though this looks good,
it's really not that efficient
because when people
want to use the cluster,
they can't always get
instant access to it.
And so we looked around.
We looked at the
different cloud providers.
And something that really
meshed well with Pandora
and what we're trying
to achieve at Pandora--
it was a good fit for
GCP and the Google team.
And I think the
things that stood out
for us is really the
distributed computing expertise.
Google has a very rich history
with distributed computing.
You know, Hadoop is based on
the original Google File System
and MapReduce papers.
More recently, announcing
the really cool innovations
with Spanner and the kind of
novel way that they handle
distributed transactions
across the globe.
That's pretty exciting, too.
One other thing-- while
this talk and our focus
so far has been on
analytics, one of the things
that's been a challenge
for us at Pandora
is real-time
distributed computing.
We built a sharding layer
on top of Postgres way
back in 2011,
because there weren't
a lot of choices for helping
us scale out for real-time data
storage.
So right now we're
focused on analytics,
but we're doing
some investigations
with both multi-regional Spanner
and BigTable as potential data
stores for our
real-time services.
So that was a really good
fit, and Google's focus on AI
and machine learning was a
really good match for us.
The investment in
TensorFlow, the ability
to run specialized computing
hardware for graphics,
the TPUs, is pretty exciting.
In particular, we had a lot of
success with BigQuery, as well,
and we'll go into
more details as we
get into the meat of this.
So we kicked off an evaluation.
Just to give you kind of
a sense of the timeline,
we're a good size
organization, and this
was a big change for us.
So it took some time to get
buy-in from the business,
to get everybody aligned, and
make sure we're moving forward
in the right direction.
So we kicked off some
preliminary research
into the various cloud
providers at the end of 2017.
In Q1 2018, we did
a proof of concept,
spent about three
months building that up.
And by the end of that, from
a technical point of view,
we knew what we wanted to do.
We knew we wanted to go to GCP.
We spent a couple months working
with a lot of the stakeholders
around the business,
our partners in finance,
building out a financial model.
Something that was
tricky for us is
that we had this big
investment on-prem.
We had a colo lease that
went out several years.
We had a lot of hardware
we'd already invested in.
And so how do we make
the switch to on-prem?
It's not-- or to
GCP and the cloud?
And it's not something
that happens overnight.
So it took some
creative work there
to make the numbers work
out, but we got to a point
where we feel like when
we finish this migration,
we're going to be in a good spot
and very comparable, cost-wise,
to where we are today on-prem.
So the end of last year, we
started our migration planning,
trying to figure out
the priority of how
we migrate and move forward.
In Q1, we migrated some
of our initial datasets.
And at the end of
this month, we're
looking to get our first
set of early adopters
onto the GCP platform,
which is pretty exciting.
Still a long way to go,
but making great progress.
So with our POC,
what we did was took
one of our largest datasets.
So this dataset-- it's called
MADDS, Master Advertising
Delivery Data Set.
It's really all of the ad
impressions for all the ads
served on Pandora.
It's a very large data
set-- one of our largest.
About 15 billion records in
this data set every month.
We keep a couple years,
actually two or three
years, of this data around
for long-running campaigns
and to do history.
So moved this process up
onto GCP leveraging Dataproc.
It's really a Spark
job that combines
a lot of different data
sources into one data set,
normalizes that data,
and abstracts away a lot
of the business logic,
that downstream consumers
of this data--
so they don't really
need to know about that.
So this all went really well.
We found increased query
performance with BigQuery.
I'll get you some
numbers in a minute.
The batch workload
was also optimized.
About 35% fewer resources to
do the same amount of work.
And then this
consolidation I mentioned.
We were able to move
all of these sources
into a singular table.
So this is my favorite slide.
What we did was we took
the gnarliest queries
that we ran on-prem
on this dataset,
and we ran them
against BigQuery,
ran them against our
Presto instance on-prem,
against our Hive on-prem.
And I think not only
the quick results here,
but the consistency across
all, under 30 seconds here.
Very reliable.
So this was really,
really exciting for us.
So as we talk about
the migration,
this is a long process.
We have a lot of jobs running
in the cluster, a lot of users
on the cluster.
We think this is about
an 18-month effort.
And we're part of the way in.
You know, originally
we did a pilot.
We moved a couple
of datasets up,
different types,
got some experience,
did a lot of the
infrastructure work.
Cloud is new for us.
I'll talk about
that in a minute.
But it's a different
animal, and there
was a lot of learning there.
Now we're deep into
the core datasets,
migrating the datasets
that are most heavily used
by the company up there.
We'll do that.
And then there's going to
be some long tail, and also
an opportunity.
We've built some
tools that tell us
really what's
being used on-prem,
how often it's being used.
And so to do that, we've
been able to prioritize
the workloads that
we're moving over,
and I think we'll do some
spring cleaning, as well.
So areas of focus.
I mentioned we spent a lot of
time on the infrastructure one
to get right, and it
was a new muscle for us.
So we leverage
Terraform very heavily.
We want everything to
be really repeatable.
Between our operations
team and our tech ops team,
they built essentially
a project creation tool.
So someone that wants to go and
use the GCP platform at Pandora
now goes to a portal,
gives us some information,
gives us some contact and
relevant information about what
this project is
going to be used for,
and that kicks off some
Terraform that goes and creates
the project, gives them the
right set of permissions,
and does things in a standard
and reproducible way.
So that was really cool.
VPCs were another thing took
us a while to get right.
We worked a lot with
the Google PSO group
and some of the product teams.
Learned a lot there.
But also automated
that, as well,
so the VPCs get attached
to these projects
as they get created.
Also, important thing
for us was budgeting,
so being able to map these
projects to different budgets,
and understand what
that use case was going
to be because even now, over
just our short time on GCP,
I think we're at, I don't know,
nearing 100 projects or so.
And then of course,
the users are
going to be an important track.
It's a switch.
We use Hive.
We use Presto on-prem.
BigQuery is still SQL, but
there's some nuance there.
There's some UDFs that
we'll be transforming,
and it's going to be
a learning process.
We think we're going to do
this in a few different tracks.
We'll have some training for
different types of users.
We've got the administrators
that have been kind of trained
up already.
Different tracks for a
developer, scientist,
and analyst to learn
about the platform.
So this is really cool.
Very early on, we figured
out that we actually have
a lot of cruft on our system.
We've been around
for a long time.
We want to make
sure we're spending
our time moving the things
that are most important.
So shout-out to one of our
engineers who's in the audience
here, Kate Shimada.
She went and created what
we call the lineage tool,
so scraped all the logs
from our on-prem cluster.
Think timeline server logs for
TES, job history for MapReduce,
some logs for Presto
and from Airflow.
Kind of pulled all that
data together, figured out
the relationships, parsed
the actual queries that
are being run, and
figured out things like,
what are the top queried tables?
Dependencies between datasets--
what are two commonly paired
tables that people
join on together when
they're running queries?
And then what are the
least queried tables?
What are things that just
aren't really being used?
And those are prime
candidates to be axed and do
a little cleanup.
So as we get into
migration, we took the data
from the lineage
tool, broke it up
into functional areas of
work, assigned leaders
to the different areas
of work, and then we're
actually also
using the same tool
to check off datasets and
jobs as they get migrated
and move over to GCP.
All right.
I'm going to hand
it over to Blake,
and he's going to go
a little more deep
into the technical details.
BLAKE DUBOIS: Thanks, Brett.
[APPLAUSE]
So I just first want to call
out the team in the timeline.
So first off, Google
PSO engaged with Pandora
in around November of last year,
along with a wonderful partner.
Some of those members are in
the United States, Neudesic,
so this was really
a combined effort
between Pandora's excellent
engineering organization,
Neudesic, and Google PSO.
And we're going to tell
you a little bit about what
the architecture
looks like in GCP.
So one of the first
things we did is target--
Pandora has a large,
monolithic cluster on-premises,
and Brett did a really
good job of showing you
some of the inefficiencies, and
some of the bursty workloads,
and some of the drivers that
pushed them to the cloud.
And so they were also facing
some operational burdens.
And so they really
chose GCP Dataproc,
which is GCP's completely
managed Hadoop platform.
And we really run Dataproc
in two different ways.
So on the left-hand side,
we see that we spin up
Dataproc job, Dataproc
clusters, in around 90 seconds
or so that are scoped
to particular jobs.
So this is ideal
for batch or ETL
processes that get
run on a daily basis,
if not more frequently.
And so what we see
here is that we're
using Apache Airflow, in the
form of GCP Composer, a managed
version of Apache Airflow,
to basically identify
how much data needs to
be processed, spin up
a right-sized Dataproc cluster,
do the ETL or batch process,
and then persist the result
back to Google Cloud Storage
or push it into BigQuery.
On the right-hand side,
there are some use cases
that Pandora undertakes, like
the use of Hive or Presto
for interactive query, to
support 150 or so users
throughout the day.
And these are served best
by long living or moderately
living Dataproc clusters.
These clusters can
actually be spun up
in an optimized
fashion per workload.
For example, Hive may need a
more balance between compute
and memory, while
Presto would have
more memory-intensive machines.
It also allows the Pandora
team to speed up new clusters,
test out new
versions of software
via new Dataproc
images, to see if they
can upgrade to a new version
of Hive or Spark, et cetera.
On the edges of
some of these things
are some operational tools
that are used on a daily basis.
So these include things like
Google Stackdriver, which
has direct integration
with GCP Dataproc
to pull out a lot of YARN
metrics, amongst other things,
as well as like Google
Cloud Logging for IEM,
and other metrics.
And then lastly,
on the edge nodes,
clients can use
edge nodes either
in the cloud to spin up
Jupiter or Zeppelin notebooks,
or they can also access
across their interconnect
from their on-premises systems.
So now I'm going to walk
through all the pillars
of a successful data
platform on GCP,
and what are some of the
things that Pandora--
some key decisions
they had to make,
and what steps that
they had to take.
So the first thing we're
going to talk about
is data ingestion.
So Pandora has over 7 petabytes
of data on their Hadoop cluster
on-premises today,
and they needed
to devise a plan to
get that into GCP.
So the first thing
is connectivity.
We typically, when we
work with customers,
look to see which pattern
is right for them--
either moving it
across the wire,
or using some type of
transfer appliance.
In this case, Pandora, when
we started working with them,
had a 10-gig link.
That was to GCP.
And over the course
of the project,
that was increased
to 40 gigabit.
We also learned
throughout the project
that, like Brett mentioned
earlier with his comments
on VPC, network design is key.
So working with
infrastructure folks
in the beginning to make sure
that you have that foundation
is very, very important.
Next, now that we had
connectivity established,
we had to go, how are we
going to get data into GCP?
How are we going to get
into Google Cloud Storage
to realize that separation
of compute and storage?
So there's really three
different patterns
for doing this.
And for those that
are interested,
these slides will be
posted in PDF form,
and this is actually a link.
So there's push, versus
pull, versus kind
of having a proxy cluster.
So I'm going to focus
on push versus pull.
The push model is, we have
a Hadoop cluster on-premises
that you install a GCS
connector JAR into,
and you point it at
Google Cloud Storage
and move the data over time.
The other scenario is you can
spin up a Google Cloud Dataproc
cluster in GCP, point it at
your on-premises cluster,
and pull the data.
There are pluses and
minuses to each approach,
and you can read
more on the link.
So Pandora decided to
do the push model-- use
their existing cluster
to push data into GCP,
one of the easier options.
But to do this, they kind
of ran into an issue.
There is a mismatch
between checksums
between Hadoop historically
and Google Cloud Storage,
and not just Google
Cloud Storage,
but object stores in
the cloud in general.
At a high level, this has to
do with a mismatch between MD5
and CRC checksums.
So one of the senior staff
engineers within the Google
Cloud Dataproc team developed
a patch, HDFS-13056,
which is a patch to HDFS.
So the Google PSO
team, Neudesic,
and Pandora collaborated
on this patch,
and applied this to Pandora's
on-premises cluster through
a dev, test, and finally a
rollout to their 2,700-node
production cluster.
So this really allowed them to
move the data from on-premises
to the cloud, have assurances
that the integrity of the data
was preserved, so that they
can start deleting datasets
from on-premises, and
that has just started.
Next is when dealing
with data copy
when moving from
on-premises to the cloud,
you have to be cognizant
of data access.
And so what I primarily
mean about that
is the cost of ingress and
egress from Google Cloud
and cloud in general.
The first is ingress.
So as we moved the
7 petabytes of data
from on-premises
to the cloud, we
don't have to worry
about that charge.
It is completely free.
But we do have to be
cognizant of egress charges,
and they come in two main forms.
One is across zones
in a particular region
and when moving between regions.
This is especially
important when
dealing with disaster
recovery, and we're
going to talk a little
bit about that later.
But lastly, due to Pandora's
major investment in BigQuery,
it really softens a lot of that.
So any query egress from
BigQuery is completely free.
So when you're serving
analytical applications or BI
tools, either in the
cloud or back on-premises,
any egress from
that engine is free.
And the last thing I just
wanted to share about the slide
is that there's a
great, excellent blog
post that goes into the
details between the HDFS patch
that is required to
ensure data integrity
between on-premises Hadoop
clusters and the cloud,
and you can read more by
clicking the blog post link.
Next thing I want to do is talk
a little about cloud storage.
So we're moving data
into cloud storage.
In an on-premises Hadoop
cluster with HDFS,
there's not the nuanced
durability, availability,
resiliency in the storage.
There is a concept
of storage tiering,
but there isn't quite the
same analog into the cloud.
So the first things
that we had to deal with
were storage classes.
So Pandora worked
with the PSO team
to understand what was
right for them, based
on the different
datasets that they had.
So datasets come in
a few major flavors,
so gold master datasets
that need to be highly
available at a low latency.
They need to be backed
up and available
to any type of DR system.
There's data that's created
due to intermediate processes
of analytical jobs
that can be rerun.
And that data requires
less resiliency, but high
performance.
And lastly, there's
just intermediate data
that analysts use throughout
the data science process,
and that may not need high
resiliency, durability,
or performance.
And so what you see here
is an engineer at Pandora.
Iggy really empowered
his organization
to understand all these storage
classes via the decision tree
on the right.
And then next, moving
on, is permissions.
So a lot of times
I go and I work
with customers who are
storing a lot of data in HDFS,
and it's kind of amazing
to see, although this
isn't the case of Pandora,
that the majority of jobs
are accessed and a
majority of files
are owned by the Hadoop user.
And so when moving to the cloud,
having to understand IAM--
Identity and Access
Management-- service accounts,
and principles is key.
So we were able to implement
a project-based inherited
security model with projects
being scoped to applications
and projects being available
for dev test and production
to encapsulate the security
of the actual application
and its data.
So this goes without saying,
but separating the compute
and the storage really alleviate
a lot of pain customers
normally experience,
as did Pandora,
that when HDFS gets
above 90% or so capacity,
that it can bring the entire
cluster to a grinding halt.
So that is a problem that is
completely alleviated by moving
to GCP and GCS.
It also increases transparency.
So now that you
have data up in GCS,
you can really point any type
of analytical engine at it,
and it's very, very easy.
And then lastly, we talked about
where we are in this process.
It's very early
days for Pandora.
But some of the discussions
that are already ongoing
are around object
lifecycle, which usually
requires custom tooling.
Certain scenarios that
are covered under this
include what happens when a
data scientist or an analyst
takes a gold master dataset,
runs a bunch of analysis on it,
makes a lot of analysis
result, and it's just
sitting in a GCS bucket?
Now that you have access
to unlimited storage,
you may start seeing a little
bit more cruft laying around.
So how do you manage that?
How do you ensure that the
permissions are correct?
How do you ensure
that datasets are
known to be either
intermediary or gold?
So on and so forth.
And so while manual
processes may work at first,
it's very common to build
custom tooling to automate this.
So here's the real meat
of the data platform
today using Cloud Dataproc.
So there's a few different
ways of using Cloud Dataproc,
and I've tried to
break them down here
in four different ways.
So we talked about
ephemeral versus
long-living Dataproc clusters.
And so Pandora basically settled
on the four following methods
for using Dataproc.
So the first is long-running
Dataproc clusters
that run workloads
like Presto or Hive,
but are capable of auto-scaling.
So when users are not
using these clusters,
they can scale down,
save cost, et cetera.
But whenever people come in in
the morning and start firing
queries, that they
can auto-scale.
The next is
long-running Spark jobs.
The workload is
streaming workloads.
These take advantage
of auto-scaling,
but may not scale back down
due to some of the concerns
around intermediate data.
And then the next two are
around ephemeral clusters.
So ephemeral clusters,
or job-scoped clusters,
can be brought up to do ETL.
They can be created
in 90 seconds.
We can create a cluster
that has 500 nodes that
will run for a period
of minutes, which
would cost the same as a
one-node cluster running
for 500 minutes,
and just really see
that immense
speed-up in the cycle
time for the particular job.
And while these don't
necessarily auto-scale today,
they can be dynamic at startup.
So when you're using Apache
Airflow or Composer to create
these clusters, you can identify
how much work is being done,
and pick the amount
of nodes that should
be used to perform this job.
And then lastly is
ephemeral clusters.
So jobs that may need to copy
data from one place to another,
or perform some
type of operation,
like analyze tables in Hive,
may be created a ephemerally
to spin up and spin back down
in a short period of time.
So there's a few
things on the right
that I want to talk about,
like over the last five
months that we were able to
realize pretty easily by using
a managed Hadoop service.
So the first thing
is Pandora was
able to upgrade to Hadoop 2.9.
So you saw that they were
running HDP 2.6.4, which
was Hadoop 2.7.2, and it had a
lower version of Hive, as well.
So with very little
effort, we were
able to adopt a Dataproc image
with Hadoop 2.9 and Hive 2.3
and realize some
performance gains.
The next is I want to talk a
little bit about customization
of Dataproc.
So Dataproc has base
images, but they rarely
have every single component that
a customer may want to utilize.
And that was the
case with Pandora.
So Dataproc offers a series
of top-level components
that are baked into the
image that are enabled
or disabled based on flags.
And so what this means is
since the bit's already
built into the
image, you can have
a litany of components available
within the 90-second cluster
startup time.
And so what this
means is that you just
write in an
initialization action that
has configuration and
not necessarily bits that
need to be installed, because
the sum of installing all
those bits across a
cluster, even a particularly
large cluster, could
be very costly,
both in performance
as well as cost.
And then lastly, we talked a
little bit about auto-scaling
for Dataproc, but I do want to
talk about workflow templates.
So workflow templates are a
recent innovation in Dataproc
that really allows you
to spin up a cluster,
run a graph of jobs, and then
let the cluster spin back down.
So this really,
really simplifies
the job-scoped ephemeral
cluster model where you once
had to create a Dataproc
job, submit jobs, and then
understand when to
shut down your cluster.
This is now completely
wrapped for you,
and easily called by scheduling
systems like Airflow.
Next, I want to talk a
little about Cloud Composer.
So Pandora is a very big
investor in Apache Airflow.
They primarily run
Airflow 1.8 on-premises,
and have over 90
instances today.
These instances span the gamut
of dev, test, and production.
They have an extensive
set of plugins
that they use to do
some really cool stuff.
One of them is job dependencies.
So not only do
they have a series
of plugins that will manage
job dependencies across Airflow
instances, but they also manage
dependencies across legacy
schedulers, and now recently,
they've added functionality
to also mention dependencies
across the cloud, as
well, which is GCP Composer,
which is managed Airflow.
They also have a lot
of cool operators
that do things like sense
whether data is in HDFS, sense
whether or not a
partition in Hive
is available to
basically enable jobs
to understand if they can move
down their dependency graph.
Continuing along
with the plugins,
there's also CI/CD built
into the Airflow instances.
Since Airflow is so
pervasive at Pandora,
it shouldn't come as a shock
that it's not just engineers
that use Airflow.
It's a lot of analysts
and scientists, too.
So how can you enable these
people to quickly write a DAG
and sync the updates
to the system?
So they have a update
DAG view plug-in
that works across Airflow
and Composer in GCP.
Last, when we
started this project,
upgrades to Composer in GCP were
a little crufty, to be honest.
So there was custom
scripting that
was required to upgrade minor
major versions of both Composer
and it's underlying Airflow.
And we're really happy to
report that as of Next, I
believe yesterday, new
functionality was introduced
in Composer that completely
automates both tools upgrade
automatically.
And then lastly, I just want
to talk through this system
on the right.
So the partner that I called out
in the beginning of this talk
really took the lead in
developing a Composer DAG
factory.
And so what this
is is a framework
that runs in Composer that
encapsulates all the jobs that
are being migrated to GCP
from Pandora's on-premises.
And so it really just wraps
analytical business logic
in a lot of prechecks, sensor
checks, task retries, logging,
et cetera, validation,
and then also
queues other processes for
downstream processing, as well.
And so this DAG factory is being
used to wrap all of the jobs
are being moved to
GCP from on-premises.
If you want to learn
a lot more about this,
you can catch this
great session that's
taking place tomorrow morning.
So Dan Barrett, a staff
software engineer from Pandora
who's in the
audience here today--
he's going to be speaking
with the Composer
team about Pandora's
move to GCP and Composer.
That's tomorrow morning
at the Metreon Theater 7.
So next is BigQuery.
So Pandora has recently been
experimenting with BigQuery,
and is settling on a production
architecture for its use.
And so I'm going to step
through a couple of concerns
that customers typically
have to understand
when they adopt BigQuery.
So the first is
workload management.
So first off, before we go
into to BigQuery, just a few
concepts for those that
are unfamiliar in the room.
So BigQuery has a
few constructs that
are important to understand
before we go into this.
The first is a slot,
which is basically
just a construct of a fixed
amount of memory and CPU.
You have a slot pool.
So when you interact
with BigQuery,
you have a series of slots
that you either use on-demand,
or you have a fixed
reservation of these.
In this case, Pandora
has 2,000 slots.
They can make as
many reservations
underneath that slot
pool as they would
like for workload management.
And this overall hierarchy
is called the reservation
hierarchy, and
you see an example
on the bottom right
of the screen.
So workload management is
really here to enable SLAs,
and this allows you
to really maximize
your investment in BigQuery.
So what I mean by
maximizes is that what
you see here is to
enable some SLAs,
we're breaking apart
our slot reservation
into batch and online.
And we're giving particular
projects and particular
applications a fixed amount
of computing and memory power.
But if some of
these reservations--
I mean, if some of these slots
are unused by these child
projects, other projects can
actually burst in and use them.
So if, for example,
the MADDS project
is done with its
daily computation
and is not using its slots,
Zeppelin users-- data
scientists that are trying to
use the systems-- will benefit.
They can actually just go
over and take those slots.
The next is federated query.
So BigQuery traditionally
works on BigQuery storage.
It's a highly optimized
both file format and storage
layer for BigQuery that really
enables true interactive query.
But increasingly,
BigQuery supports
more and more federated
query sources.
So some of those include Google
Cloud Storage, Cloud SQL,
and a few others.
There's wonderful announcements
on that at Next 2019.
So you can federate a query
across a variety of formats.
So the formats that
Pandora primarily uses--
Avro, Parquet, ORC-- the
majority of those formats
are supported for
federated query.
And BigQuery supports columnar
data partition support.
So if you have data in
ORC or Parquet format,
primarily ORC, BigQuery
will understand partitions
and actually do predicate push
down and optimize the query,
even if it's stored
external to BigQuery.
What does federated
query enable?
Storage tiering.
So it's very common
for customers,
and in Pandora's case, to
store their most hot data,
their last 90 days,
in BigQuery and then
push older or more
historical data into GCS,
and then do federated query
across the two datasets
when historical
analysis is required.
The next is high throughput API
and external analysis engines.
So we're innovating
with Pandora.
The Google PSO team is working
to build a BigQuery storage
handler that allows Hive
and Presto to register
external tables against
BigQuery datasets,
and this will allow for
further federation of queries.
So data that is
historically preserved
in GCS for multiple years
can be actually merged
with the hot data in
BigQuery and queried
with one analytical engine.
And then lastly, exploration is
kind of taking place with BQML.
So for simple regressions,
classifications,
and increasingly
other ML methods,
BQ is kind of making
it effortless to run
those against datasets in BQ.
So some parting
anecdotes about what
we were able to accomplish
over the last five months
include an approach for GCP
speed disaster recovery.
So like Brett was
mentioning, there's
an active cluster in California
and a DR colo on the East
Coast, and they're following
a similar model in GCP.
So their primary
region is us-central1,
with the DR region
being us-east1.
And so there's a
couple of advantages
of using the cloud
for DR. So the first
is that you don't have to,
in an active standby mode,
have resources be running
in your disaster recovery.
And if you needed to
actually replicate
your entire production
environment in the cloud,
that's possible by moving
to a second region.
But there was one
really neat thing
that Pandora was able to
adopt within GCS that is going
to make this quite effortless.
So GCS has a bunch of
storage tiering modes.
So for those that
are unfamiliar,
there's multi-region GCS
storage, regional GCS storage,
and a special type
of multi-region
is called dual region.
What this does is pin your
data between two regions
that are known.
So that's especially useful in
disaster recovery scenarios,
amongst others.
And so this NAM4
bucket type within GCS
is used by Pandora to store
its most important data
and ensure that it's replicated
from us-central1 and us-east1
continuously, and allow
them to spin up and continue
their business in the event
of a disaster in us-central1.
And they can do that via CI/CD
tools, and infrastructure,
and code that they've developed
throughout this project,
as well.
And then lastly, kind of ending
with a really early success
story for some of the
other tools in GCP.
So there's the Pandora
Music Genome Project,
so I encourage everyone to go to
pandora.com/about/mgp and learn
a little bit about this.
It's a very comprehensive
analysis of music over time.
And what this is is
batch feature extraction
and prediction using TensorFlow.
And so traditionally
at Pandora, this
was done on a single server
using other ML libraries
and it would take
a matter of days.
In the example
here, over six days.
So analyzing over
10,000 MP3s, extracting
features for analysis was
just done very, very slowly.
And they were able to quickly
port that over to Dataflow,
after this data was
loaded into GCS,
and bring up like 800 cores
and complete this same effort
in less than four hours.
And that's just the start of
what they're doing with this.
And so with this, I'm
going to pass it over
to Brett to talk about
what Pandora is going
to be doing for the
rest of 2019 and what
we kind of hope to see them
talk about at Next next year.
BRETT UYESHIRO: Thanks, Blake.
[APPLAUSE]
So just try to finish
off real quick so we have
time for a couple questions.
We are part of the way down
a pretty long journey here,
but some things we're
already realizing
is the separation of
storage and compute
is one of the biggest wins that
we're getting out of the move
to a cloud.
Enabling this
flexibility to scale out
when you really need to,
when you have a bottleneck,
has been really cool.
As an example, we
have this job that
processes-- it's essentially ETL
on a lot of our listener data.
It has probably the
worst name possible.
It's called the Nightly Job.
It was the only job back
in 2010 when we wrote it,
but it still does a lot of the
core processing of our listener
data.
That used to run, or currently
runs, on-prem in just a little
over five hours.
We moved that over to GCP.
It's running in Dataproc
now, and it runs in, I think,
an hour and a half.
So that was a big bottleneck.
It's a big dependency for
this long chain of jobs
that we run every night.
And so being able to scale
that out, reduce the time,
puts us in a good
position to finish
all of the other
nightly processing
and be ready for the next day.
The operational
overhead-- well, let
me talk about
Lift-and-improve a little bit.
So being able to
migrate, we didn't
want to just lift and shift,
take exactly what we were doing
on-prem and move it to a cloud.
So all these things I mentioned
about being able to scale out
have really helped us there.
The ability-- a
Hive upgrade used
to be a really big
endeavor for us.
It took us about
a year from start
to finish to test
out the major Hive
version to get all of
our different teams
that have tested the
job and do that upgrade.
And now with Dataproc, and
having ephemeral clusters,
and having jobs being able
to use whatever version they
need to, we can do this in
a much more staged fashion.
It gives us a lot more
control and flexibility.
And the last thing I would
say is, lean on Google.
Lean on the PSO services.
They've been a great
partner for us.
A big migration like this--
things do not always go right.
Features aren't
always as advertised.
That's just the fact.
People use them
in different ways.
But Google has been
a great partner.
When we found an
issue, we reported it.
They get back to
us very quickly,
and we're iterating on it.
So we really appreciate that.
We know everything's
not going to be perfect,
but when you have
a good partner,
it makes a big difference.
Also, early access to features--
we got early access to Data
Catalog, which has been great,
a lot of BigQuery features
that we got access to early,
so that was really helpful.
So what's next for us?
We're really focusing
on optimization.
So we're going to
finish the migration
beginning of next year.
Along the way, we're doing a
lot of optimization for cost,
for speed, and then
really digging in
to see what we can
leverage with all the tools
to improve the personalization
and listening experience
for all of you on Pandora.
[MUSIC PLAYING]